Alors, comment est la vie d'
un criminel international à la retraite ?
pris
il y a une semaine, il joue avec votre tête les
dames mortes doivent savoir avec certitude
arrêter monsieur bien mieux que cette poubelle
nous y voilà maintenant nous avons travaillé avec des
œufs de faucon pour respirer des cibles Owen Shaw pour une
majeure en SAS SpecOps soldat
vous obtenez toujours Letty nous  Je t'aurai Shaw
mais nous avons besoin de quatre parties tout
autour et parce que assurez-vous que vite
tu dois être une guerre meurtrière jamais vue
celle-ci
tu penses que tu as gagné ce rhume dans lequel tu
vis concerne la famille est la raison même pour laquelle
tu  n'étaient même pas dans le jeu